[Musik]
fragt warum meine Fresse so rot ist ich
hatte gestern den Gesichtsbehandlung und
das sah gestern tatsächlich sogar noch
so aus
eure Tomate aus dem Gemüseabteilung
Einkauf ist übrigens so riesig dass die
einzige Möglichkeit diese Caps zu tragen
ist das oben offen zu lassen
es hat eine Menge drin ne
falls euch übrigens fragt warum ich
schiebe ich bin gestern Abend in der
Scherbe gefahren und kriege ich jetzt
einen neuen Reifen drauf gezogen guten
Morgen Sandra ich würde niemals in den
Hubschrauber steigen
ich verstehe nicht wie die Teile fliegen
kann guck mal das ist Kölner Architektur
hier so richtig modern der irgendwelche
alten Sachen ganz am Ende steht noch
raus irgendwie so ein Baukomplex und da
damit diese Sachen
versteht mich
[Musik]
hier wurde auch einfach ein Wohngebäude
direkt an der Kirche dran gebaut ja ich
verstehe irgendwie gar nichts mehr was
ich aber sehr sehr sympathisch an Köln
finde ist das tatsächlich vor 9 Uhr gar
nichts geht in der Stadt alle sind am
Schlafen ich habe jetzt zwei Jahre in
Hamburg gelebt da war gefühlt um 6 Uhr
schon übelster Trubel in der Stadt aber
hier alle Leute sind irgendwie
Langschläfer ach du scheiße Digger
da lauf ich einfach mit die fange jetzt
schon an die Schilder hinzustellen dass
es bald alles abgesperrt ist
[Musik]
Gott gedreht die Filme irgendwas
mediales gemacht Tauben sind die
schlimmsten Tiere weil die einfach so
unfassbar dreist sind ich habe schon so
auf fast eine Taube überfahren weil ich
dachte die fliegt im letzten Moment
nicht weg ne es gibt keine schlimmeren
Tiere die sehen auch so unfassbar
hässlich aus
[Musik]
Fahrrad habe ich abgegeben
komplett gefangen
ah die nächste Filmproduktion aber ein
bisschen ernster zu sein
also einfach insgesamt zu 20 Leute hier
am Set ach keine Ahnung
[Musik]
der komische Platz in ganz Köln ist
übrigens der Friesenplatz du hast zwei
Gebäude die extrem schön und modern
aussehen und zwei die komplett abgeranzt
sind doch 25 Grad und wir haben schon
Weihnachtsbäume da stehen locker schon
drei Minuten und ich habe mir gerade
erstmal Frühstück geholt
aber was passiert doch nicht mehr so
viel ich falls du Frances gesagt
übrigens eine Couchtische Lamborghini
getroffen also was heißt getroffen
werden kurz
braune Haare 87 und staufenring Köln
melde dich
[Musik]
da oben habe ich früher gewohnt
und ich bin jede Nacht aufgewacht von
dem Bahnen die hierher gebrettert sind
und von den besoffenen die sich da
hinten achte habe ich einen reingegnet
haben da vorne haben wir mittags immer
gegessen
luvietnamese ich schwöre euch besser
laden das war meine Taschentücher
2014 hat angerufen die wollen ihre Witze
zurück und das ist übrigens der beste
Inder in ganz Köln und ich verstehe
nicht warum die Werbung machen weil der
Laden ist eh schon immer vorne ich will
nicht dass er noch voller wird natürlich
da sind wir wieder da wollte ich damals
mal hinziehen in so eine
Zweizimmerwohnung und ich fand voll geil
weil ich habe in der Zeit heute auch
immer dabei gewohnt eigentlich wollte
ich mir einen Fahrrad jetzt ausleihen um
zu Francesco zu fahren allerdings ist so
schönes Herbstwetter gerade
oder Tomate
[Musik]
guten Morgen Sandra ich frag mich voll
was ich Leute denken die hinter mir
laufen ne ich grüße die ganze Zeit
irgendwelche Mülleimer
ich dachte ich
[Musik]
wenn ich
eine Fußgängerampel
überquere die rot ist
sie wird aber grün während ich sie
überquere also während ich auf der
Straße bin ist es dann immer noch
verboten
es sind die wichtigen Fragen die ich mir
am Morgen stellt ist ein Zebra weiß mit
schwarzen Streifen oder schwarz mit
weißem Streifen
das habe ich denn jetzt hier für Modus
aktivieren ultra coolen shot gemacht und
mich dabei gefilmt wie ich gelaufen bin
und so getan habe ich überall Leute
größer aber da war ich gar keiner
dicker ich bin das größte Opfer der Welt
ne
ich sag einfach gerade schon
[Musik]
ein Fahrrad
du stehst genau
ich bin ein Jahr langer Fan und wollte
mich mit dem Riegel bei Dir bedanken für
die Jahre die du mich auf Youtube
begleitet hast und einfach mein Auto
gezeichnet und mir Protein wiedergeben
wir schreiben eine gesamte Körper
und das ist der wildeste Typ in ganz
kleinen
Apple watch
ultra Hauptsache
[Musik]
schwarz
komplet
[Musik]
ten vergangen
ich habe die ganze Zeit nur Videos
geschnitten und fahre jetzt abholen weil
wir dann ins Gym gehen schon wieder
diese Kamera ich liebe dich
Protein
[Musik]
wir sind durch mit dem Training
ich fahre jetzt nach Hause und muss
eigentlich duschen und danach noch auf
die videodays also dieses Youtuber
Events
ich pack das nicht packst du das
irgendwie bin ich froh dass du langsam
wieder der Herbst kommt
eigentlich ist es meine Hass Jahreszeit
weil man weiß dass man die längste Zeit
noch vor sich hat das wieder der Sommer
kommt
[Musik]
aber
so milde Herbstabende fühle ich
irgendwie gerade das ist schon so ein
bisschen am dämmermann ist oder was
heißt der Mann ist schon fast sehr
dunkel oder so habe ich heute aber
eigentlich nur mit Bloggen angefangen
weil ich eben genau dachte dass ich
gleich auf dieses Video days die werden
gehe und ein paar coole Youtuber treffen
Sandra und so sind da
ja und halt auch andere Youtuber aber
jetzt gehe ich genau dort nicht hin was
eigentlich der Sinn des Vlogs sein
sollte
scheiße ich gehe jetzt auf jeden Fall
ins Bett
wenn sie keine Kommentare zu meiner
Friese ich hatte den ganzen Tag eine
Kerb auf dann sieht das immer so aus und
ich freue mich jetzt einfach nur auf den
Bruder hier
ich liebe mein Schlafzimmer das wie so
ein Hotelzimmer
wir sehen uns die Tage wieder im neuen
Blog haut rein ciao